قضي الصفحات ال8 ولجنه الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر اتتا في وقت حساس جدا من علاقه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده فانعدام الثقه
كان في ازدياد خلال الفتره الرئاسيه
لباراك اوباما المشكله الان هي ان
السعوديه تقول انها ستسحب 750 مليار دولار
من استثماراتها في امريكا اذا تم نشر هذه
الصفحات التي لا نعرف محتواها هل هناك
دليل قاطع يشير الى معرفه او تمويل او دعم
الحكومه السعوديه لمختطف هجمات الحادي عشر
من سبتمبر ام انها تشير الى ان اثرياء
السعوديين دعموا تلك الهجمات الامر ليس
واضحا لكن السعوديه لا تثق بامريكا حاليا
لانها لا تعتقد بان واشنطن حلف فعال كما
قامت المملكه بتشكيل تحالفها السني الخاص
في المنطقه من 4 بلدا وزادت من انفاقها
على الدفاعات العسكريه لتصبح ثالث اكبر
منفق على الدفاعات في
العالم